now who is that
oh him he's nobody not nobody
he is part of the kitchen he's a plunger
or something he washes dishes or takes
out the garbage he doesn't cook
but he could uh you know
how do you know what do i always say
anyone can cook
well yeah anyone can i love that line
anyone can cook i don't know if that's
true
but that is a very famous song from the
2007 disney pixar film
ratatouille now some tick-tock users are
trying to prove
anyone can make a broadway musical super
fans have started composing original
songs for an adaptation of the movie
about the talented chef who just happens
to be well a rat
lad duties spoke to some of the
influencers who first cooked this
up remotely of course vlad hey again how
did this start
so gail like many viral moments recently
this one came out of boredom brought on
by the quarantine
tick-tock user emily jacobson started
the trend in august when she wrote and
then
posted a short song inspired by the
movie soon
others started joining in and now
jacobson says she hopes that it's more
than just a tick-tock trend
i wrote uh the original song back in
august that became
kind of the musical theater anthem of
the ratatouille musical movement
that's emily jacobson by day she's an
elementary school teacher
but she says music and disney movies
have always been a part of her life
i happened to find this article about
the ratatouille ride coming to disney
world
and i just started singing this like
random little song about the main
character
that main character is a rat named remy
who dreams of becoming a chef
[Music]
not long after daniel merksliff another
tick tock user who works in musical
theater
put his spin on the song
[Music]
others quickly followed suit to help
create ratatouille the
musical don't waste your whiskers i'm
dreaming
we have everything we need just take a
look and you will
all see takes is courage
merch love says remy the rat's unlikely
friendship with a human who helps him
achieve his dreams
strikes a chord with many people what is
it about ratatouille that has
so many millions of people
jazzed about it the movie itself uh it's
it's an underdog story remy and linguine
should not
get this done there's no reason that
this should work
even broadway actors like tony nominee
kevin chamberlain are getting in on the
action
you know what i always say anyone can
cook
i think the most exciting thing right
now
is because of the pandemic art is
pushing through
[Music]
you probably have one of the more
popular songs
like in america right now yeah you know
it's like most of the people that are
contributing these amazing songs are
just
everyday people a lot of them kids these
are going to be the next stars
[Music]
kevin chamberlain is a very big star you
can see him in a musical coming out on
netflix
in two weeks starring meryl streep and
nicole kidman called the prom
we asked emily what her plans for her
crowdsourced
musical are she said while it takes
more to make it to broadway she really
hopes that disney will use it in some
capacity
moving forward we'll have to wait and
see but this is it's choreographers it's
makeup artist
it's incredible going to be a lot of
songwriting credits in that musical in
the end wow i love that it started with
an elementary school teacher yeah who've
been they've been going crazy through
this pandemic
emily either and i now you're all going
to be singing vlad
[Music]
it's going to be your work all right
thanks